all right ah so I can start all right
all right welcome everyone this is Grand
Master Alexander Linderman and who can
recall us what was the main theme in
last week's my greatest losses theme you
know what was the main pattern in common
in the last time yeah
mm-hmm
well yeah you got you got it yeah you
got the main point what anyone wants to
add to that well well we're basically
what he was saying that you got a
develop yeah exactly yes so you have to
make sure that you don't fall behind and
development and okay sometimes it's
trickier then then other times but it's
still important to stick to the basics
okay well today we're gonna you know go
over games where I lost because of
either having bad pieces making some of
my pieces bad or not restricting my
opponent's pieces or in other words
having my opponent's pieces too much fun
so also a different kind of sense of
danger but more like a strategical kind
instead of like more of a dynamic one
all right so we're gonna start off with
the loss that I had against the
International Master Craig he'll be and
this game was a pretty bad the game that
badly played game by me but you know
it's a game we can definitely learn from
so I was white and my opponent you know
he needed the three out of treats who
get his norms so he was trying to play
for a win and trying to play a an
unbalanced game so he played a six he
played a system with a 66 so I didn't
know the line I unfortunately I didn't
really check this before the game and I
decided to play it very safe with g3 but
the more principled this is aligned with
h4 in general whenever the night is
going to e7 and up ones on g6 h4 h5
makes a lot of sense and depending on
what black does let's say h5 now e4
could be pretty good because after this
takes takes bishops coming to g5 and
applying some pressure on that night
forcing some more weaknesses
you mean here yes you know you can also
do that but then I can go fish before
Queen d2 and now the point on h6 becomes
a problem
so yes h6 is definitely a typical idea
to meet h4 with h6 but basically
whatever black tries to do he's gonna
have to make some concessions so I think
white is better but I played this
castles Bishop g2 d5 so now at least in
this case he's able to kind of shut down
my bishop like that and here for some
reason I just you know had a brain cramp
I took on d5 which is of course
completely unnecessary it would have
been much better to just Castle here
because when I took on g5 I helped this
Bishop become a better piece and in this
position um I guess I was afraid of this
a little bit but then of course I just
go here Knight a5 over t1 and there's he
can't ever really take on g4 and
I will get the pawn back and we'll be
comfortable so and of course later I
played more like this in another game it
was a little bit different move water
there but I had something with c4 g3
already played and so it's still useful
to know this position but of course I
didn't take on g5 but in this game in
this game I took on g5 he took IDI I
castled he played knight c6 which okay
he can also play c6 but he's trying to
apply some pressure on this it's also a
system here so I played B 395 III Knight
c7 and now I played before and this move
is actually very controversial
the reason it's controversial is well on
one hand I'm trying to prepare tension
to prepare minority attack in case black
plays c6 or something defending the
spoon but on the other hand very more
importantly I'm giving up control over
the c-4 square in a long run and that
thing is very very dangerous
so it's movies you know
very risky but I kind of knew it was
risky so but I still shouldn't have
played it there should be to Bishop III
just play a kind of a neutral move
although at this point I'm not already
better
it's just position but it was one of
these I was trying to create probably be
two but I mean I can't say looked I
studied this game that deeply to know
the differences and even if I do it's
not a position that the computer will
understand that well the difference is
it's like very very subtle I mean even
for a world champion you know such a
difference is hard but intuitively I
would say more likely be two but these
are not the kind of decisions which
usually impact the game because it's
like bishop beats or Bishop a3 the
difference is very small I mean even if
it turns out you put it to her own
square you can always go back the thing
is with the pawn push you can't take it
back that's why it's a more spin more
kind of responsible kind of move and
references Sam Franklin spoken
bon bon play so black played a six here
I played a four and he played c6 now I
play drop a three because I'm preparing
to play b5 and he cannot play b5 because
I take take take
so 96 b5 okay I'm giving up the porn but
of course I will get it back in many
different ways porn and b5 will be very
weak so my opponent played 94 now here I
missed an you know an interesting
decision which would have at least
guaranteed me to get a maybe not a
better position but like also like much
more comfortable game that I got in the
game so who can come up with an
interesting decision for white here in
this position
addy
sorry
so second the exchange arm that's
interesting but I don't know if we need
to okay so Queen B 3 I'll take take take
take yeah I mean this could be could be
interesting but here I think I'll be at
least ok because I've you know here
you're giving up the exchange for for
just without even getting a point for it
you're just given the up to exchange so
actually your idea the concept was good
but the execution could have been better
so what you should do is you should take
on c6 and now black has a choice if he
takes here then I can go to b3 and I
still create a little bit of a weakness
but more importantly I do not open up
that file the a file does not get opened
up and that's like a huge plus for me
compared to the game if it takes you
tonight ok that's you know there are
also nothing opens up so the critical is
this but this is actually a little
inaccurate because then I take and this
is just like a you know this is what
addy wanted but now we get an extra pawn
out of this and now D 5 volts becomes
weak and the bishop on g7 is biting on
granite 494 staring at it so then I can
play Queen b3 91-93 as my arrows dictate
I have control over the c5 square all of
my pieces are potentially very good and
I have a good chance of getting the
second point so I'm definitely not worse
here so that would have been a very nice
decision to take on c6 instead I played
rugby 3 I guess I just you know
underestimated the danger of this moment
I thought this no harm no foul but now
he gets a little something he gets an
open file as well and now he plays a
good move he plays Knight of 596 to
secure that night on a good square
before developing the bishop like this
move would have been inaccurate because
then this Knight is unhappy so first
team secures that night and then he
worries about where the bishop belongs
take stakes and now at least here I
should have sensed the danger that man I
mean I'm very passive and my opponents
pieces are very active and if I just
play a couple of small slow moves I can
really get into trouble so this was the
opportunity to play e4 maybe and
unbalance the game slightly it was
double-edged but it was still better
than what I did in the game and that
game I played Queen c2
he played Knight d6 I played rugby one I
wanted to get the rook in the game
somehow and I thought okay I give him a
tempo but I didn't really see what's the
big problem here
and I thought here I didn't really sense
how you know bad my position already is
but the rule is any kind of passive
position has potential to be a loss you
know that's like the general rule of
thumb so Queen c7 was played and now
Knight h4 and here I was already sensing
that I'm definitely not better and maybe
a little bit worse so even though I'm
playing a lower rated at this point I
was happy to repeat moves and make a
draw but my opponent to his credit
played played the game on which you know
it's gift gives him a lot of respect
because you know it's not like he's
totally winning or anything like that or
like it's not like he's like easily
clearly better but despite the fact that
he's playing somebody almost 200 points
higher with black he's still you know
playing on the position and I was you
know very impressive in my opinion and
it's not like I even offered the droids
like I repeated moves so you know it's
it would have been very tempting to just
say okay let's make a draw but you know
that was you know that just goes to show
how he was really ready to play this
game
okay so takes Queen takes now he has
control over both B and a file and again
I'm still kind of suffering to find
counterplay so I played this he went
here
well the idea is if he goes here right
away then would be one so so that's why
he played here first securing the bishop
saw Roxy one queen bitsu knowledge for I
think Bishop c2 and now maybe queen bee
- something like that yeah so that's why
he now put the bishop back to five so
Roxy one queen bee - now we can see how
he's really getting control over the
position so here he is playing it
patiently he sees he does not have not
knockout blow so he just played h6 using
the fact that actually I don't have a
useful move like I mean I'm for me it's
very hard to find a move so he finds a
move that is useful in every case and
lets me figure out what move I should
play very good mature move
so I played 91 but that probably makes
my position a bit worse Queen a3 now I
can't go here because of this so Knight
h4 Bishop e6
Knight c3 and now he pushes my knight
away and you know that's where the h6
move became very useful because now he
just simply goes back with the bishop in
opponent g5 you know now there is never
any kind of counter play when I teach
five-night h4 and certainly the move is
very safe because there's no way white
can open up the game or attack the Kings
so g5 is totally not a weakness it's
just like restricting my knight
so I played 90 to 94 but now this Knight
comes here Bishop before Queen b3 what
else
you can't just say
take one queen protects everything so
bishop before the Queen b3 Bishop c3
okay - okay so now he's threatening rook
takes issue as well in the knight takes
c3 so Bishop f1 and Bishop g4 yeah that
attacks my knight now rugby one Queens
a4 and now I play the King G - so here
black has lots of promising ideas
questioners which is like the most
knockout one here I was still hoping for
like a chance for a bailout but c5 if I
don't know I think I control that
divorce square pretty well anyway so I'm
not sure if it has really any bite
because even if c5 you're not really
threatening anything even if you take I
take with the bishop world I have too
many pieces on that square so it will
probably not be yes but I don't have to
take anything that's that's the point
while I was thinking that a c6 phone is
actually kind of leaked if you can
oh yeah well that's true but I mean you
know here you have such a dominating
position and you're really having such
active pieces I have potential attacking
the king that you don't really want to
preoccupy yourself with how weak to see
six points I mean in this position
they're like things way more important
yeah yeah yeah no I mean and that's
something that actually I was hoping he
would do and then take the rook right
yeah that's something I was hoping for
because at least here I mean I'm
probably lost but at least I have
control over some light squares and even
the endgame I was thinking maybe it's a
little chance Knight comes to a five
maybe a little bit of a chance of a
fortress not very realistic but I
thought okay at least here I can still
grovel on for some moves so at this
point you know that was you know my hope
but my opponent you know unfortunately
for me found a much you know more
authoritative way to play
he saw that [ __ ] takes f3 is something
I can't really stop anyway so he just
played Queen c2 he is playing for a
mating attack because now he well I'll
show you shortly what he thread so for
example let's say I go here here in
Bishop before so what would blood do in
this position then
take the night King takes
yeah this sure takes cleany formate
although although of course this is also
winning but you know this is matin one
yeah so the point is you know black is
having this huge threat and I cannot
stop it so I tried to play Knight fg1
but this is of course you know very much
a disaster takes takes takes then he's
coming in here so he won the pawn but
the attack continues that's the problem
and now he just took and he just come
came in here and the rest is easy
pickings and you know that's how the
game ended with made like this so this
was a game where again allowed that
night on c4 I allowed my opponents rook
ought to be on the a file I just allowed
my opponent to be too comfortable I
allowed too much piece activity to my
opponent and that was the main reason
why I lost the game and even a low-rated
as a result was able to play a very
strong game like that
alright so now I'll show you a game that
I lost to hammer young Ludwig here in
st. Louis and in one of these fall
classics hammer young Ludwig is pretty
strong GM 2650 or something like that
2662 at this tournament so the opening
was relatively slow nothing that much
was happening
and the both sides are playing
relatively logically
logic of moving the Queen to c8 I wanted
to take on c4 or go d4
twenty-seven uh I was
no but if takes Bishop takes be seven so
I wanted to prepare you know moving yeah
so Queen b8
again this is this part is not like so
relevant I mean for for the main team
its it was just like he yeah yeah here
here it was more like yeah sure
yeah here but here it was more like I
mean okay then the opening was
interesting but I wanted to just get to
the main theme of the game that's why I
went through it a little bit
yes so this is an interesting moment
right here so here if I wanted to play
it safe I could of course just trade
Queens and play rook c8 and I don't
think I ever lose this position I just
bring the king in the game and we
probably shake hands here but I was a
little bit on business here I thought
I'm a little bit better because I have
won and c5 he has opponent III and I
played this move but this move I think
wasn't very good I think I should play
Queen e7 was idea being I'm trying to
stop his play my goal is I have this
space advantage so I need to protect
that space and then I just need to go to
g6 King g7 and maybe start a little bit
of an initiative on the Kings side and
if I wanted to play for a win that was
probably the way to to go instead I
played like this rook c2 and I went for
something very concrete but it's always
a very risky dilemma
you know whenever we're going for a
concrete play but it's anti positional
and this is again like one of these anti
positional moves where we're giving up
our space we're hoping that something
will work to work out concretely but if
it doesn't then you know we lose our
positional Trump's so it was a move that
was risky and it did not pay off
you know this move I should not have
played he took I took and he played
Queen of three just defending everything
I played rook c8
no I played h6 first
King Jitsu and now I ended up bone queen
before so already I'm kind of realizing
that my Queen and c4 doesn't have any
bite so I'm trying to reposition my
pieces but now my opponent was having a
little bit of an initiative and here it
was a little bit annoying I feel like
yeah I gave my opponent some play which
he never should have had so Bishop e5
rook c1 rugby eight I don't remember why
did that I may be just getting the rook
out of potential attacks oh well I think
the main problem is not so much that
it's more like he has control over the
open file the C files I think probably
the more annoying part so b3 queen a5g4
so again he's looking for a way to
create some problems he sees a hook I
have one on h6 so he's looking for a way
to create some initiative in the
meantime he was going for this f6 or
Ooty - I have to go here I cannot go
here my ideal square because then takes
takes takes it takes
so queen f5 Roxie - rocked XD - night XD
-
rugby 894 Quincy 524 and here I ended up
playing Quincy five I really wanted to
play rugby for here but there is a
reason I didn't do that
who can tell us I mean this is a little
bit of a tactical exercise for you who
can tell us why was rugby for not good
even though may be tempting potential
grenade Chuck King h7
and now strong with 93 and here just
coming in here I still thought maybe
root X before I could make it work but
unfortunately after King age 3 it is
just not working and it was very
frustrating rook here takes takes Queen
f3 and I just have a bad end game and I
was very annoyed after I lost the game
when my opponent told me that he would
have gone Queen g6 and he had one minute
on the clock so he might have done that
but then I saw that I'm actually okay
Quincy v f3 Bishop c7 and that was you
know and here I'm okay
93 Queen a5 and so on so that was you
know a little bit unlock here but I get
slapped for all of us you know because
we can learn some new things from the
way the end game played out so Queen d5
Queen takes rook takes it looks safe but
I know it's a little bit unpleasant
because I thought that he still has that
pressure along that C file so I went
back 92 Bishop d8 Knight f3 King of 7
rook c8 and now question is okay what
would you do as as black in this
position
well you know it depends on how you
evaluate the position right so first you
have to evaluate what you think the
position is you know whether you're
slightly worse or you're slightly better
or its equal you know and then you know
based on that you know try to make a
decision
the young
rub t7 and enough let's say I play 94-94
bishop where 0.86 um yeah but here I
think I you know we're suffering a bit
right rook c6 maybe you know forcing e5
at some point here I was sorry my bad um
yeah here I think yeah this is a little
bit unpleasant I can you know play a
movie h5 I can play rook c6 here I think
it's not quite equal or suffering here
so we don't really want to go into this
defensive crouch so the best move was to
realize that my bishop on g8 became from
like a very good piece early on so now
it's like a struggling piece so what I
needed to do is I needed to get it in
the game play a5 and try to create
counter play with some Bishop f6 and
then you know I think I'm doing
perfectly fine it goes after this it's a
prophylactic ins this by the way because
fish takes h4 and after h5 a thing you
can play a4 and stuff rookie no not
another four maybe a five first and then
at some point you're looking at a four
and Bishop f6 and you know we have we
have counter play here black isn't
really all that much worse maybe not
worse at all well any move would have
almost any move would have been better
than the move I played in the game and
the move that played in the game is very
a once again based on concrete play but
it's very bad positional I play the
movie 5 and now we have a big problem so
you see we have a dark square bishop and
in those position I have literally all
of my pawns on dark squares and I ended
up putting that one last one that was
still had potential to be on a good
square I put it also in a dark square
that means I'm completely bankrupt on
the light squares completely bankrupt I
gave them all out to that night and now
my opponent can totally create a light
square domination starting with which
move yeah very good
h5 because we're need to activate that
night so get it to a5
or maybe g6 dominate the life scores by
the way if or would have been that
because then after room t3 we're giving
up a lot of dark squares but sensually
would be five this should be six and
we're creating new weaknesses so h5 of
course if he didn't have it five maybe
if I've would have been acceptable but
because he has h5 it's like I it was a
prophylactic against 94 but it was one
of these that cure was worse than the
disease than the disease because the
night anyway is able to access the into
my territory the night anyway is able to
get into my game so I'm not really
stopping the idea I might have stopped
like a certain move but I didn't stop
the main idea for him to activate the
night and now I've only weakened you
know new squares so I played here night
h4 Bishop e7
okay now you're white how would you try
to continue your technique here how
would you try to convert this
we're moving the night - geez
pass that's possible sheesh what do you
think okay any other ideas
before I never liked that move because
Bishop c5 or of the two you're giving me
counter-plan the dark squares you're
giving my bishop much more life which we
don't want to do we want to restrict
that Bishop keep it restricted well lets
me ask you this question logically so we
don't know yet whether you won tonight
on a5 or on g6 it's like both are
possible but what move in this position
is a move that we need to play any way
to improve our position in the endgame
yeah yeah so that's why he played king
of three without too much thinking why
because King of three we need to play
anyway we don't declare our intentions
it's a flexible move now in some cases
we might go Knight a5 some cases Knight
g6 but we don't need to show our hand
yet here so this should be for King e4
rook D 2 rooks e7 King g8 and now King
comes in you know now you see how
bankrupt I am on the light squares you
see what was the consequence of putting
all my pawns no dark squares it made my
bishop kind of an empty piece without
too much purpose and in the meantime I'm
just losing on a light square because he
has three pieces attacking me now which
I cannot really stop I tried route
except two now what's the most precise
move here King g6 or King e6 yeah
very good because after this there's
Bishop f8 for example and after this
routes you to and suddenly black is
counter place so you have to be very
careful and concretely with concrete
play even in a winning technical
position but King e6 kind of seals my
fate because now there's just 986 rook
c8 and I cannot stop the mating net so I
tried f5 now it's still not too late to
go wrong with knight c6 allowing this
and this and black is winning suddenly
so of course there's you know we have to
be patient just take on just go check
bishop f8 and take that route e2 but
there's no maid of course and here I
resigned because I'm gonna be ended up
in a King and pawn endgame which is
totally lost and that was the game so in
this game it was a problem of you know
having a bad Bishop restricting my own
Bishop just you know losing because of
in a bad piece and making my opponent's
pieces stronger so once again lack of
attention to a piece activity in this
game at that point yes it's just I well
I I kind of played too many poor moves
on the dark squares age 6 and stuff but
especially you know in the end that e5
kind of sealed my faith if I don't play
5 it's still fine I think at that point
they were probably roughly equal pieces
maybe why the night was still
potentially a little bit better but not
by that much but yeah I was it was a
pleasant one for me and it was at a time
when I was doing well the tournament
three and a half out of five and you
know that was my first loss in that
tournament and then I lost the one right
after that as often times happens all
right now we're gonna take a look at my
loss to Richard the report and I'm again
playing with the black pieces
so my opponent played an interesting
system Bishop d3 with the idea of the
ship C to D for very well it's not very
common against the it's more common of
when the pawns on g6 not so much when
the pawns on East six because here I
could just play for d5 but I played here
so he canceled
I played d5 and now he play d5 nidus up
alright what do you guys think whites
should do in this position
yeah rook e1 rook e1 is like the most
tempting move it's the first move that
comes to mind but now this move would
have actually gotten white amazingly
this early in the game he could have
gotten into lots of trouble because of
an innocent-looking move because black
has a very strong move in this position
so who can so can try to find that move
so very instructive Queen c7 is not
gonna you know be so dangerous because
then I can play this should be five
anyway or I can go Queen e2 so Queen c7
is okay but it's not gonna be you know
anything that's yeah c4 Queen c7 the
same thing Oh Queen b6 yeah but still
all play d4 okay why is this so so scary
okay rookie two bit before next maybe I
mean okay black has a fine position but
so does white just normal position yeah
we're looking for a way to really get a
an advantage here after a p1 yes
to slow still a6 b5 okay I'll just go
here and D for me it's not gonna be
anything yeah d4 also nothing that
special mill develop night III let's say
and then try to challenge the point on
g4 again it's a normal all of these are
moves are normal but there's an idea
that's very powerful here as black a
very unconventional like somehow people
miss it but it's it's a very good idea
to know about it turns out this knight
on f3 is really short and squares and
we're also kind of targeting the spawn
in many different ways but we can play
this move yeah
yes very good yeah g5 because now we're
threatening g4 n g4 wins the piece so
white has no time for Bishop e5 or
anything like that so if you can you
know even if we can let's say attack the
knight you know let's say here even if
white plays something like this now it's
suddenly a position where it's blacks
the one who is attacking for example now
you can play your c4 idea you know Queen
c2 95 and we can see that now we have an
h-file open and we can always even
Castle queenside if we really need soo
so the attack is very much in our favor
the g5 idea is actually a very common
even in the French positions you know in
these closed variations whenever the
center is closed
you know whenever the center is closed
like that and potentially White has this
kind of structure or maybe white hasn't
had time to get the structure this g5 is
a very typical id action in these
positions and something you have to
always be in a locale yeah that's why
such a move works that's why my opponent
where the correct move he played Bishop
b5 so that was a good move I played a6
that move maybe wasn't the strongest but
it was still kind of okay takes takes
and now what do you think White's should
do in this position
d4 would be a positional mistake because
then after this we have now we're making
this other pawn relevant we're gonna be
able to place c5 this should be seven
and we're gonna start chipping away in
the spawn as well and we can under ball
the pawns we open up the game as black
we have two bishops were very happy so
we want to make sure in this kind of
structure we keep this Bishop on c8 kind
of restricted so that best move is d3
followed by c4 I mean maybe c4 right
away also makes some sense but I think
d3 is you know pretty logical but just
not with not d4 so Bishop e7 here I had
an interesting idea of going aged 65 and
then Bishop g7 but I didn't really think
about that I played here now next few
moves young he plays c4 so now I
realized he wants to go Knight c3 Knight
a4 so I realized I had to do something
so I played f6 I decided to strike while
he's not completely developed yet which
was a good move takes takes and of
course I saw that the spawn is not
really a very good point to take because
after I take take what is black to here
best move yep not even know you can even
it you can even just take this because
they're second mates all over the place
takes takes takes a mate
again pieces are asleep so I knew that
so that's why I knew he cannot take on
e6 I calculated that I mean intuitively
I felt he cannot take and then my
calculation was there to verify that so
93 96 and here he played the move Knight
a4 so the idea is he wants to trade the
Knights and after I took if I take here
he would take here and then take here
yeah yeah because black still has some
weaknesses so he played takes takes and
I played Queen d6 and now he decided to
undo all his my pawns
what would the concrete idea in mind he
wants to go guitar for and create some
initiative you know chase McQueen around
and also fight for the square which
makes a lot of sense Queen b6
and now he played rookie too so you know
kind of indirectly defending the
opponent b2 I mean I can take it still
but then I thought here maybe I'm
slightly worse but maybe it's okay for
me like some Bishop d7 or verse 65 it
was complicated I didn't want to go into
that I played Bishop e7 he played Bishop
e5 and this is a this I think is a
critical moment of the game which I I
kind of probably I don't I don't think I
realized this was critical move so it's
black to play and how would you play in
this position
yes very good very good a she she got it
right away
d4 this should be 7 and then Bishop d5
that way this side this move does two
things number one it shuts the Queen
down from going to g4 and fair from
playing for initiative and number two
I'm I'm saving the square for my Bishop
Bishop goes to d5 and yes I'm
potentially giving up c4 square but
again you have to give something to get
something sometimes in chess and even
though he can do that but I'm winning
the pawn here I mean yes you might get
some compensation but it's nothing so
scary and otherwise I'm going this
should be seven Bishop d5 and here I
would have felt very good here I would
not be worse maybe a little bit worse
but nothing's too scary instead of that
I played a bad move Queen b5 and of
course he will never trade with me
because the endgame is gonna be only
fine for me in this position by the way
it's worth noting that a move like
Bishop d6 is not very good either
because there has two weaknesses number
one is that we still have the v square
control with the knight
right now we have a dilemma where both
pieces want a five squares like two kids
fighting for the same toy pieces are
redundant but after this you know now
Knight comes to e5 and also this pawn
becomes weak you know we remove the main
protector and also whenever we have a
bad piece like a bishop on c8 or
something we usually don't want to trade
down to other pieces because then we're
kind of stuck with that bad one so
that's why it's important to keep this
one and d4 would have you know been a
very good move I
Quincy for ya mate so I mean okay rook
f7 you can play but you already allowed
the Queen in you know that's you know so
queen b v queen g4 and we saw how much
problems later that queen created for me
so once again it was a station where I
didn't make the most of my pieces and I
allowed my opponents pieces too much
momentum rook f7 Rach do you want okay
he needs to defend the t3 pawn bishop f8
Queen h3 setting up 95 Bishop back when
she 3 and now I play d4 but a little bit
too late and now he played h4 and I play
the move that was probably not very good
I played h6 creating some new weaknesses
in particular the g6 square I mean I was
trying to stop 95 but it was probably at
this point better to just allow it
because now he found a very nice
maneuver after which he has a much
better position
Knight h2 exclamation party he's simply
preparing the idea of going Queen g6
followed by Knight g4 and I don't really
have a good antidote against this idea
it's very powerful play King h7 for
example h5 so it's a very tough position
for me already probably lost evaluations
around +2 here because his pieces are
just flooding in so I played h5 he
played here
I played c4 trying to go for desperate
counter play he took I took he went here
Queen d5 and night of 3 okay so cannot
take that obviously still made there
should be 7 rook takes d4
tween-deck say to Roxy seven Queen a one
King edge to the stakes of three alright
and now white to play find the finder
finishing finishing touches of this
beautiful game by opponent
yes raka for very good good start
raka fate we want to continue there
should be six yeah but I think then I
can then you're losing control over this
is a little bit complicated I think also
I aren't you like pinned here you know
the bureau could spin it yeah it's a
little lamb it should be six you know
you don't really want to move the bishop
away from you five ideal it's too good
of a piece you want to try to look for
moves Bishop d6 is just too complicated
we want to look for a moves that yeah
rookie seven if I take yeah
oh no I'm I don't think I'm not sure if
you're meeting me though and you're down
a rook okay
yeah this is not mate and okay I mean
you might still have some initiative but
it's not really the clean-cut solution
yeah
okay thanks
they are also defending so sometimes
when we see a certain tactical idea but
it doesn't work with one mover we have
to look for sometimes switching the move
water that's a typical thing with yeah
take the bishop first Oh
a rook f3 yeah I mean rook f3 is
certainly you know the the safest one
and it certainly is winning but I think
you know I can play a queen e1 or
something okay the game continues a
little bit I mean there's a way it's or
just it's like forced made here but you
have to just you know find a move that's
Queen takes I don't know I'll play with
Bishop g4 maybe it's also not so clear I
think again you know the Queen on g6 is
doing very well well we're trying to set
up you know so that Queen decks of seven
or OPEX of seven will lead to mate but
if we start with this and then we're
gonna go see eight then you would give
him Bishop f8 so just try to find us
Divya yes rook c8 and this is game over
because again I'm still tied down and
now he's just threatening Queen decks of
seven what mate I'm g7 and I cannot take
any of the rooks because of take it here
here take here here so I had nothing
better than to play rook f6 try to but
it only prolongs the agony he took with
the rook I took here
it took here and I let them make me same
kind of made us against Craig he'll be
by the way on a save square just from
the other side so it's again it's very
instructive you know when is whenever
you're attacking and you see you have a
tactical idea that doesn't quite work
and try to look at it from a different
move water sometimes that can help you
solve the problem that's like a very
important tactical motive and another
thing to keep in mind is whenever you
see a certain tactical idea
you know it's it's it's whenever you see
a certain tactical idea and let's say I
move and this mover doesn't work it
still means you have to keep and keep an
eye on that idea later because later on
something might change and that idea
might might work all right so let's see
one more game and this game is a game
against Amelia Cordova another strong
Chiam and I'm again black and this was
like a pivotal game and in the
pan-american continental championship
which thankfully I still was able to get
into the World Cup from that despite
this loss but at that moment it was very
unpleasant loss you've played him where
oh nice yeah I mean he's currently
studying at Webster by the way Cordova
okay so we're gonna not spend too much
time in the opening since we don't have
tons of time anymore he played an
interesting idea with a three fighting
for initiative a three before I played
here and he played before here I have
several ways to play but since I didn't
know the line I decided to play it safe
and played e6 I could have went for this
line but somehow I didn't really
consider that I only consider taking
with a pawn after which I thought I'm
this is the kind of game I didn't want
to play I didn't want to give him any
initiative because I know he's good with
the initiative so I played here and now
we're just developing pretty routinely
certainly both play for both sides could
be maybe improved a little bit but again
for the grand scheme of things it's not
such a big deal okay so here's the first
interesting moment of the game where I
feel like I made a practical mistake and
well so first of all question to you
guys is what would you play as black
here and then another question would be
then I'll explain to you how I should
have thought about this position and how
I you know did not think correctly about
this position okay so what do you think
okay
yes yeah rook t6 is certainly possible
but okay then game continues like 95 and
everything you know it's normal game so
as you might guess since I stopped you
guys you know there is something
concrete here yeah
very good yeah so that's no your ideas
you know making a lot of sense and of
course I consider this move so I knew he
has to go here and then I can play
Knight b3 so I saw that but the reason I
rejected that and I thought about this
for 20 minutes
because I thought he goes here and the
problem is then I cannot go Knight d4
anymore because he takes and after this
he takes back with the knight two pieces
four ropes so that's not working so then
I thought about okay rook takes d3 but
then I thought position is very unclear
he can play night shift I think I
thought I think I saw rook c3 and I was
just like I thought my pieces are
getting tangled up and I just couldn't
really work it out it was very
complicated but I couldn't really work
it out so but the mistake I made from
practical standpoint of view was that I
should not have tried to calculate all
out instead I should have looked here
and seen so I have any alternatives to
rotex d3 and it turns out I actually had
the move Knight back to a5 here because
now a white has a tough choice he has to
either go back and make a draw or he has
to go here but now this is very
unadvisable for him because now he his
rook is misplaced on c3 and now I can
play queenie 796 Road d7 and it's like
yeah he's a lot his pieces are awkward
the placed his harmony is spoiled but
maybe sign I should have known at the
very minimum I'll have this so like the
cost the risk is not very high even if
it turns out the Bishop a4 doesn't work
out even if it turns out that here rook
takes d3 doesn't work I'm not risking
anything here so that should not have
been the reason for declining to play
Bishop a4 because she's you know you all
know that it's much easier to see two
moves ahead that four moves ahead right
so the point is I should have done these
moves and then here's where I should
have been thinking here is where I
should have tried to calculate rotates
d3 where they worked plus there would
have visit there was a chance you might
have just gone here
after which like again now I again I
have a pleasant choice
I can go Knight a5 or I can go 90 for
winning the exchange for a very minimal
compensation well okay not winning the
exchange I mean but I mean he probably
would have done this and play for some
compensation instead of instead of going
here which just loses the pawn for
nothing
so the point long story short he was he
was he would have had to make a tough
choice does he go rogue do you want and
allowed certain these sorts of problems
or the single Roxy Tzu which allows
different set of problems right he would
have had to make a decision and while
he's thinking then I can figure out do I
play Knight a5 and go the safe route or
well here would have been would have
been much easier to figure out this move
and then even after this I have lots of
moves even the move like quintic c4 and
for example 95 takes takes and takes you
know I think I think there was or maybe
it's no here I just take sorry by my
mistake I think it might have been after
Knight II one that I do this this and
this so the point and after Queen B to
that 994 based on this idea so the point
is the tactics do work out for me
but you know again it's hard to see in
advance but the more important thing is
that I have a bail out option just going
Knight a5 and this is why I should have
went for this even if I couldn't see all
the way through till the end in the
other line does that make sense to
everyone that's like the practical value
of the calculation I shouldn't expect to
see everything in advance especially
when I have a bail out option instead I
didn't do that I was a mistake in
calculation in judgment I played here
and now he started some initiative on
the Kings side I should have by the way
played Bishop e7 like Bishop a8 was a
little bit too too much
and now he starts he starts his
initiative and the question for you guys
is this what would you plane was black
in this position and this was you know
the critical moment
okay so go ahead if five is interesting
move but problem is where I think giving
up the t5 square is a bit too much
because now our rooks become irrelevant
and now whites getting too much play and
that's the same problem with g5 by the
way because g5 there's anyway 95
otherwise g5 would have been a good move
if I can play like h6 and there after
that I type this they wouldn't would
have been very good but 95 was the was
the problem takes takes and then this is
also weak yes very good very good Ashish
yeah you actually just have to take the
pawn you know this was like semi-bluff
the point is if I do this I make my
knight relevant my knight is actually
becoming a very good defensive piece it
who goes from like it becomes it you see
that piece on g7 in this position it's
like a stupid piece but after age five
this piece suddenly becomes relevant now
it has a very important role it kind of
keeps my king site intact right and it
prevents white from really breaking
through and in the meantime I have ideas
like Queen f6 Queen h6 and maybe at some
point throwing in h4 if he ever moved
the night and then you know I have you
know actually I'm a BAM better in this
position because my opponent can't
really do much in this position he's
kind of his attack is kind of running
out of steam you know and I'm just you
know very very comfortable in this
position
I mean it will I think I don't know I
mean well he doesn't have that much if
he doesn't play h5 anyway so it was like
kind of a semi-bluff which worked it was
a practical choice you know maybe it's
it's a Rebecca tallness you know he's
like an initiative player so sometimes
you know initiative players go for
something a little risky you know when
they take chances I think mathematically
maybe it is but it's fine even I take
such five would have been okay but
instead I played a very bad move 94 and
why is this move bad well because I've
played this beautiful plan doubling the
rooks and now my selfish knight goes
right into d4 blocking in both the rooks
so the selfish Knight wants that square
all to himself and now both of my rooks
becomes completely stupid and now
White's Initiative just you know takes
the second gear because of that so again
it was one of these games where I did
not think about pieces in the way I
should be in my games
so I played rock g7 and now he took took
a knight h3 and suddenly he has very big
initiative and unfortunately here my
position is still not so terrible but I
just collapsed here I played here and
then I played there then I played back
so this whole night h5 was not good I
should've at least played 98 and then
tried to do this but yeah here I just
collapsed
I take back I guess I mean it's not like
he can't but I mean I was I was very
happy to get rid of that night on e5 yes
so I think this was much stronger for
bringing my knight to oblivion and a
95-98 and now King here comes the king
then the rook and Queen g7 Rock h1
Knight of 6 yeah here good or bad I
should have done this and I should have
sacrificed the I think I should have
done it like this or something and
sacrifice the Queen I mean I'm probably
losing but and this is completely
hopeless this is just like a very
passive position where I have where I
completely tied down and I just lose he
just simply doubles now he tacks my
knight
okay and now he can win in many
different ways he chose this one and
here I resigned so as you can see in all
four games you know all kind of a
similar theme right we're just not
paying enough attention to Pease
activity whether it's my own pieces my
own piece coordination you know
sometimes it could just be one piece
sometimes it could be a matter of giving
my opponent's piece pieces to much
relevance just not paying attention
enough to the idea of relative peace
activity and that's why you know all of
these losses happens similar theme so
make sure you guys you know try to not
make the same kind of mistakes and
hopefully you guys can learn from these
games and until next time this is
Grandmaster Alexander Linderman
you
[Music]
you